crota they're waking him
hi there it's Kevin Van Horn's standing
in for reviewer Justin Clark to tell you
about destiny the dark below chances are
very good that you know how you feel
about destiny and how you will likely
feel about the dark below you're okay
with the grinding you're okay with the
farming this is destiny circle of life
the dark below does just enough to feed
it the scenario is that new non-player
character Eris morn is one of six
warriors sent to go kill Big Daddy crota
she's the only one who survives and
she's now enlisting the help of
guardians to help finish what she
started Eris is a better storyteller
than good old dinklebot though as always
with destiny the poultry story is in one
ear and out the other we could destroy
him and then there was only death we
failed you cannot destroy the soul of
crota you get an initial mission in the
Cosmodrome as an appetizer and are
introduced to a new debuff called weight
of Darkness that comes into play when
you start the raid called crotas end
from there follows a random spewing of
new content all to get you good and
ready to take on crotas end ultimately
the dark below amplifies everything both
good and bad about destiny the core
mechanics haven't changed and don't need
to since the gunplay is the one thing
that Bungie nailed right out of the
gates the campaign missions to stop the
hive from resurrecting crota are
challenging but most of them are all too
similar to the missions you played
hundreds of times before the rewards are
paltry with the exception of the new
fusion rifle murmur which at least has
some elemental tricks up its sleeve
better rewards can be had in the new
daily and weekly heroics though these
two missions are tied directly to the
add-on should you not splurge on the
dark below there
we won't have access to because of the
limitations to stand even a ghost of a
chance with most of the new content you
must grind and grind often the dark
below ostensibly requires you to be
level 28 but there's very little in the
pack that approaches doable or fun until
you're at 29 or better the new
multiplayer maps are fun enough though
fairly nondescript as far as multiplayer
maps go not giving nearly as much of the
verticality that the original maps
delivered so well even with the tweaks
that have been made like improved weapon
drops everything you do is in aid of
reaching arbitrary goals then there's
the brand new insanity that is upgrading
exotic equipment if you had exotics
before purchasing the dark below then
your progress is now dependent on xur
even having your item in stock that week
to upgrade it unless you're lucky enough
to find the new version of the exotic as
a drop ironically the most fun part of
the DLC is a five-step quest in the vein
of the exotic bounties with a nice
varied set of objectives and no level
requirements as mentioned all of this is
the lead-up to the big show
which is crotas end the first moments
are almost all inspiring beginning with
a leap of faith into an endless abyss
it's then 20 minutes of fumbling around
in the dark with your team trying to
activate new sources of light and many a
mad dash away from lamps that explode
once lit what follows is a series of
last stands in which you must wait upon
panels to magically build bridges
between one platform in the next and
you're then beset upon high level bullet
sponges vault of glass started similarly
although the stakes are higher here
endless waves of thrall and durable
knight swarm you all while you try to
coordinate who remains on platforms who
picks off the thrall and who functions
as a veritable team medic there's very
little in games as satisfying as the
sigh of relief when most of the team is
dead and someone still manages to cross
the final bridge as expected crotas end
is highly difficult and as with vault of
glass you're not making a dent
thing and tell you that least hit level
30 and so it's more destiny a fun and
problematic game that continues to be
fun and problematic the dark below is
more for the dedicated player that wants
more it's not enough to learn you back
if you've already abandoned it but it's
just enough to keep the rinse and repeat
cycle alive
you